>> Jordan: MY OPPONENT TONIGHT
IS COMEDIAN AND WRITER, HARI
KONDABOLU.
HIS NEW NETFLIX SPECIAL IS
CALLED "WARN YOUR RELATIVES."
HA!
NICE TRY, BUT I NO LONGER SPEAK
TO MY RELATIVES.
HARI KONDABOLU, EVERYBODY.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
WELCOME.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT YOUR
STAND-UP SETS.
>> OKAY.
>> Jordan: YOU TALK A LOT
ABOUT WHITE PEOPLE.
>> YUP, THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
CALLED.
>> Jordan: YES.
( LAUGHTER )
ARE YOU NOT BEING ONLSIVE?
YOU UNDERSTAND, WE'RE NOT ALL
THE SAME?
>> DON'T BE A SNOWFLAKE, JORDAN,
SERIOUSLY.
>> Jordan: OKAY, THAT'S MY
WORD TO USE AGAINST OTHER
PEOPLE, FIRST OF ALL,.
>> I KNOW THERE'S A GREAT
DIVERSITY OF WHITE PEOPLE.
>> Jordan: THANK YOU.
>> THERE'S WHITE, THERE'S
OFF-WHITE, THERE'S EGGSHELL,
THERE'S PINK.
THE WHOLE RANGE PERFECT I WENT
TO YOUR COLLEGES.
I KNOW.
>> Jordan: TALK ABOUT HOW YOU
DON'T THINK RACE IS A THING.
>> NO, I THINK RACE IS A THING
BUT I ALSO THINK IT'S A
CONSTRUCTION.
IT'S NOT A REAL THING.
IT'S SOMETHING WE CREATED,
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT AFFECTS ALL
OF US.
RACISM IS REAL.
RACE IS MADE UP.
>> Jordan: WHAT DO YOU MEAN
"WE CREATED?"
WHO CREATED RACE.
>> WHITE PEOPLE.
>> Jordan: WE LOVE TO BUILD
THINGS.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN WE BUILT RACE
AS A CONSTRUCT?
>> WELL, I THINK EUROPEANS
FOUGHT FOR HUNDRED OF YEARS
AGAINST EACH OTHER.
THEY DIDN'T SAY, "LET'S KILL
THOSE WHITE PEOPLE.
I HATE THOSE WHITE PEOPLE."
IT WAS SPANISH AND PORTUGUESE
AND WHATNOT.
ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU HAVE TO
JUSTIFY ENSLAVING PEOPLE, YOU
HAVE TO JUSTIFY YOUR
SUPERIORITY, WELL, RACE IS
USEFUL IN THAT WAY.
IF THEY WERE OTHER HUMAN BEINGS,
IT WOULD BE WRONG.
>> Jordan: WE USED IT AS A WAY
TO GIVE THEM NAMES SO THEY COULD
BECOME ENEMIES OF US.
>> THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> Jordan: IT'S A TACTIC
THAT'S BEEN USED.
>> YEAH, IT'S VERY PRACTICAL.
>> Jordan: YOU'RE A COMEDIAN.
YOU'VE ALSO BEEN CALLED AN
ACTIVIST-- YOU SAID EH.
YOU DON'T LIKE THAT?
I THOUGHT ALL COMEDIANS WANTED
TO BE ACTIVISTS AND PODCASTERS.
>> THE CRAPPIEST RENAISSANCE
PEOPLE OF ALL TIME.
I TELL JOKES.
I TRY TO MAKE PEOPLE LAUGH, AND
THAT'S WHAT I DO, AND I THINK I
DON'T NEED ANOTHER TITLE, AND,
ALSO, ACTIVISM, THE WHOLE POINT
IS TO CHANGE PEOPLE'S MINDS OR
CREATE SOME BIGGER CHANGE.
I'M JUST TRYING MAKE PEOPLE
LAUGH.
AND IF I WAS AN ACTIVIST, THE
LAST THING I WOULD WANT TO BE
CALLED IS AN ACTIVIST, BECAUSE
IF I'M SUPPOSED TO BE CHANGING
PEOPLE WITH MEDICINE SLIPPED
INTO SUGAR, YOU CAN'T BE LIKE,
"I'M GIVING YOU MEDICINE RIGHT
NOW!
DRINK THIS MEDICINE!"
YOU CAN'T DO THAT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO BE EFFECTIVE.
>> Jordan: YOU MIGHT BE AN
UNDERCOVER ACTIVIST.
>> I'M NOT AN ACTIVIST.
>> Jordan: THAT'S WHAT YOU
WOULD SAY IF YOU WERE UNDER
COVER RIGHT NOW.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
>> Jordan: THIS IS VERY
CONFIEWSING.
YOU WERE AN IMMIGRATION RIGHTS
ORGANIZER.
>> YES, I WAS.
>> Jordan: YOU KNOW I A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE IMMIGRATION
DISCUSSION?
>> YES.
>> Jordan: HOW MUCH BETTER IS
IT NOW UNDER DONALD TRUMP?
(  LAUGHTER  )
I WILL SAY THAT THE DETENTION
CENTERS HAVE BEEN BUSIER THAN
EVER.
THERE ARE MORE JOBS BEING
CREATED UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE OF-- NO,
IT WAS TERRIBLE BEFORE.
I REMEMBER-- IT'S NOT LIKE A NEW
PHENOMENON OF FAMILIES BEING
DETAINED AND DEPORTED AND PEOPLE
BEING SEPARATED.
BUT, YOU KNOW, EVEN BACK THEN,
YOU SAW THAT.
I WORKED WITH PEOPLE WHOSE
FAMILY MEMBERS WERE BEING
DEPORTED OR DETAINED.
IT'S JUST LIKE BEFORE EXCEPT 10,
20, 30 TIMES WE SAW BEFORE.
>> Jordan: THIS WAS HAPPENING
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
>> OH, YEAH.
USING IMMIGRANTS AS CHESS PIECES
IS OLD.
IT'S BEEN DONE FOREVER.
IF THEY'RE USEFUL, YOU KEEP
THEM.
NOT, YOU GET RID OF THEM.
YEARN THE DEHUMANIZATION IS LONG
STANDING.
>> Jordan: YOUR NEW NETFLIX
SPECIAL IS CALLED "WARN YOUR
RELATIVES."
WHAT ARE YOU WARNING THEM?
>> OH, IT'S NOT MY RELATIVES.
>> Jordan: OH,.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> Jordan: ARE YOU WARNING MY
RELATIVES?
>> WELL, AFTER THE TRUMP
ELECTION I KEPT HEARING A LOT OF
WHITE LIBERALS SAYING THINGS
LIKE, "WE HAVE TO TALK TO OUR
FAMILIES.
WE HAVE TO LET THEM KNOW-- WE
BIT OUR TONGUES FOR SO LONG, WE
HAVE TO EDUCATE OUR RACIST
FAMILIES."
AND I HEARD THAT AND THOUGHT
THAT'S REALLY COOL, YOU SHOULD
DO THAT.
BUT EVEN IF YOU DON'T DO, THAT
THINGS ARE GOING TO CHANGE.
WE'RE GOING TOTE GET NUMBERS.
THINGS ARE GOG CHANGE.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING YOU PEOPLE
CAN SIT IDLY BY.
WHETHER OR NOT YOU WANT TO BE
PART OF THE CHANGE ISO YOU.
SO WARN YOUR RELATIVES.
THEY BETTER CATCH UP.
( APPLAUSE )
IT WAS A VEILED THREAT.
>> Jordan: IT WAS A VEILED
THREAT.
I KNEW IT.
YOU'RE VEILING SO MANY THINGS
HERE.
YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT WHITE PEOPLE
CAN DO IF THEY ACTUALLY WANT TO
BECOME ALLIES.
>> YES.
>> Jordan: WHICH I ASSUME IS
TALK ABOUT HOW GOOD THE ECONOMY
IS.
>> THAT'S CORRECT-- NO, I THINK
WHITE PEOPLE IF THEY WANT TO BE
ALLIES THEY NEED TO GIVE
SOMETHING UP.
GIVE US PRIVILEGE, GIVE UP
STATUS, GIVE UP POWER.
LIKE IF YOU WANTED TO BE AN
ALLY, WHAT YOU WOULD DO IN THIS
SITUATION, IS TO GIVE ME YOUR
TELEVISION SHOW.
(  LAUGHTER  )
( APPLAUSE )
BECAUSE WE-- THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
YOU-- BECAUSE WE NEED MORE
PEOPLE OF COLOR WITH TELEVISION
SHOWS, HANDSOME MEN OF COLOR IN
PARTICULAR.
( LAUGHTER )
AND THIS SEEMS LIKE THE MOST
APPROPRIATE MOVE ON YOUR PART.
>> Jordan: WHAT-- WHAT WOULD I
THEN HAVE?
IT SEEMS LIKE I WOULD JUST BE
LOSING SOMETHING.
I DO STILL GET TO KEEP MY
PRIVILEGE?
>> SURE.
>> Jordan: OKAY, MAYBE WE'LL
TALK THEN.
>> OKAY.
>> Jordan: HIS NETFLIX SPECIAL
IS CALLED "WARN YOUR RELATIVES,"
AND HIS PODCAST IS "THE
KONDABOLU BROTHERS."
HARI KONDABOLU, EVERYONE.
THE FIGHT CONTINUES.